so the latest chapter of Dragon Ball
Super's manga is out and I gotta be
honest toyotaro was cooking with this
one most of this Arc has been pretty
boring to read and honestly felt a bit
phoned in from toyotaro not that I can
blame him redoing a movie b for beat
would be boring for me to do but this
most recent chapter I feel like you can
physically see him having a blast with
it I mean look at this Cell Max
oh I have both criticized as well as
defender toyotaro in the past but this
Cell Max alone really is remarkably
wonderful to look at you can really feel
him leaning into his own style and
approach with this one and the results
speak for themselves Gigi's toyotaro
please do more of this in the future